[Music]
today's question comes from ashley in
virginia she says i'm 27 years old and
wondering how people my age can ever be
able to buy home or save for a wedding
my fiance and i will make a combined
income of about 150 000 but these things
still seem like something that will
never be attainable for people our age
oh
a lot of negativity here from ashley
whoa was me you make 150 people
would
i mean they would give anything to make
150 grand a year
so here's my thing john there's
something behind this yes
number one there could be a pile of debt
to where they're going well how am i
going to save for a house i mean i've
got 2 500 in payments every month going
out to lenders because of my student
loan my car payment and the other piece
of this that i'm seeing is she's
probably looking at really nice houses
in her parents neighborhood
and she's looking at weddings that you
know on instagram that are probably
six-figure weddings and she's going how
am i gonna save up for these things
and the truth is you don't you go we're
gonna do a 10 grand wedding
and call it great and we're gonna diy
the little decor pieces that everyone
takes home and then throws away that you
hope they keep forever be honest john
you've done it
and then we're gonna go what's an actual
reasonable condo in our area that we
might be able to save up for for the
next three or four years or a one
bedroom apartment or a two bedroom
apartment right that yes they're
overpriced right now they're expensive
no question about it
but man let's say in 10 years we want to
be at a certain place or in 15 years and
by the way this is the way it's
been done for generation after
generation after generation there was a
tiny little sliver window where it was
like bonanza
but
the idea that i'm just gonna walk out
with my fancy job and buy the house that
my parents live in and
play golf at the same if you're don't do
that but to do all these get the boat
that my dad has and get the this and the
cars that it's not how it works that's
not how they did it it's not how their
parents did it before them
and people need to slow down slow down
and i think you touched on
on a good point the debt is crushing
people right the debt is absolutely
crushing people and the re the rental
the rates for rents have gone through
the roof what would you so let's say
this um i have seen some budgets that
are just they're hard people make good
money like this magical six figure
number
and they're still looking at things and
at their student loan debt at this at
this and they realize man i can barely
make it and i'm i'm making a good salary
i thought if i made this salary things
are going to be quote unquote okay what
do you tell them man well number one i
don't want to be insistent what i'm
saying yeah i mean you got to look and
say well are you doing a budget do you
have debt what if we got you out of debt
what could that do to your monthly
income well you get to keep it and so
making 150 let's say they take home 100
grand that's that's very conservative
but you take 100 grand with no payments
and we can save up pretty easily 50k a
year even with all of our expenses but
when you make 150k and it's all you're
trying to invest you're trying to pay
off debt you're trying to do this over
here you're going on vacations you're
eating out and then you wonder how
people save and so that that is the
problem i'm having with this is i
there's not enough of a financial
picture to really look at it and go
here's the issue but based on how it's
phrased it's very pessimistic on my
parents bought their house for you know
11 raspberries
and a sheep and it's like i'll never be
able to afford this 500 000 house and
the truth is you can start at 150 000
house and steer step your way up over a
long period of time that's what you're
saying that's what our parents did my
parents live in the same house they
still do for over 30 years
and so there's a lot of sacrifices that
need to be made and you and i try to
reset these stations beat up car i mean
the the illusion dave takes care of us
very very well but
we drive old beat up cars and because
they're depreciating assets and i've got
different financial goals you've got
different financial goals and our
priorities are you know like a lot of
people they want to have the nice car
the nice house go on amazing vacations
and xyz i want those too much
right i had some buddies come up from
way back in the day some of my former
students that have just gone on to do
some amazing things they came to visit
me on friday they're up here and then we
all walked out after we spent some time
upstairs at on the terrace then
when i hopped in the car one of them
said i think you're driving
and i was like yes because i choose to
right and it's not so many better than
anybody else right i sure made that
mistake when i was 27 good grief oh yeah
but you got no one to impress and that
is like a superpower
that's exactly right wow um and so my
heart breaks for ashley because you
gotta you gotta shift your picture right
and if you start out at 150k at 27 years
old hey you're winning and b
please set off on a track of optimism
and we're going to solve some of these
hard problems even if that means we're
not going to be in virginia very long or
even if that means we're going to live
in this neighborhood versus this
neighborhood or whatever and i'm not
george i do think there's a there's a
good pushback to
if you just quit drinking a latte and uh
avocado toast you'd be rich that's
nonsense right
and yet it can help but
this here actually set about saying look
how blessed we are look how we're doing
great let's put these things in order
and get going and have a smaller wedding
buy a smaller house and let's let's let
this stuff grow over time yeah i think
there's a lot of contentment that could
be had here some delayed gratification
and just setting realistic goals and
saying all right i'm 27 by 30 we're
going to be in that house and here's
what it's going to take to get there are
we willing to be all in on this goal
and that to me that's
some amazing growth can happen there as
especially as a couple uh her fiance
she's not married to so they'll be
making combined 150s they haven't even
experienced what that dual income is
going to be like yet so stay stay
patient ashley